avant que la vidéo commence je voulais
vous informer que j'organise un très
gros concours sur instagram j'ai la
chance aujourd'hui de pouvoir vous faire
gagner une belle collection tournant
autour de l'univers star wars
alors je sais ça aucun rapport avec la
vidéo mais voilà si vous voulez en
profiter il y a un lien dans la
description et dans le commentaire
épinglé de la vidéo je suis très heureux
de vous proposer sa écoutez je vous
attends sur instagram que la vidéo
commence bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans cette vidéo dédiée aux films de
black widow
je suis désolée qu'elle soit un petit
peu tardive pour être honnête j'ai déjà
tourné cette vidéo mais j'ai eu des gros
problèmes de grésillements au niveau du
micro chez pas une info contactez bref
du coup c'était mort fallait que je
retourne tous et du coup voilà ça a
retardé le truc je pensais vous proposer
à la base un trois théories autour du
film de ses mystères de la faim etc
mais je me dis qu'une vidéo un petit peu
plus générale serait plus approprié on
va garder le trois théories pour la fin
de loki bref nous allons donc traiter de
tous les secrets et mystères théorie
tournant autour du film de black widow
donc évidemment ça va spoil sévère le
film donc vous êtes prévenus bien est-ce
que vous êtes prêts c'est parti
j'aimerais commencer avec red guardian
joué par david hare bourrin qu'on salue
bien évidemment c'est une nous regardent
une thématique très intéressante est
apportée par rhett bomar diane dans le
film c'est qu'il clame haut et fort
qu'il a affronté captain america dans sa
vie c'est d'ailleurs une obnubilation
pour lui c'est son alter ego américain
qu'il aurait pu surpasser
sauf qu'évidemment on se dit tous que
c'est un mensonge car steve s'est crashé
en arctique en 1945 et fut congelés
jusqu'au début du 21e siècle pour
avengers premier du nom alors que red
boire diène nous dit qu'il a affronté
vers 1982 83
mais est-ce qu'il ment réellement
et bien pas nécessairement et c'est une
grosse confirmation sur une théorie qui
plane depuis avengers ngueye évidemment
dans avengers endgame nous apprenons de
façon implicite qu'il existerait deux
captain america depuis le début celui
que nous connaissons prisonnier de la
glace et celui de ndioum qui est
retourné dans le passé pour vivre sa vie
avec peggy carter dans avengers endgame
l'ancien nous explique en compagnie de
banner que si les pierres sont ramenés à
leur époque respective au moment où
elles ont été prises
il n'y aura pas de nouvelles branches de
réalité et c'est ce qu'il s'est passé
steve a bel et bien ramener les pierres
et mjolnir à la fin des games et est
retourné ensuite retrouvé peggy après
tout ça donc steve n'a pas créé de
nouvelles réalités de nouvelles branches
nous sommes sur une ligne continue ce
qui signifie que pendant que le stif que
nous connaissions à la base était
congelé dans la classe le steve dehanne
game faisait sa vie avec peggy et là où
c'est intéressant c'est que l'arrivée de
disney plus avec toutes les nouvelles
séries marvel et cartes complètement
toutes les anciennes donc à josh heald
et plus particulièrement
mahajan carter du coup ce qui signifie
que nous ne savons pas ce que peggy et
steve ont fait durant leur vie ensemble
la période mentionnée par red gordian
soit 1982 1983 correspond à une période
de pleine guerre froide les états unis
contre la russie il ne serait pas
surprenant de savoir que steve et alexei
se sont affrontés durant cette période
surtout que peggy carter est un agent
très important du shield est des états
unis
elle n'est pas restée inactive durant
tout ce temps surtout que si nous nous
basons sur le film de black widow
1982-83 cela correspond à l'âge d'or
d'alexei en tant que règle guardian
puisqu'il se plaint en 95 des trois
années ennuyeuse qu'il a passées dans
l'ohio
ils regrettent l'époque où il se battait
en tant que red guardian donc voilà je
crois véritablement
à l'affrontement entre steve rogers et
alexei surtout qu'il demande à black
widow aussi justement il a déjà parlé de
leur combat ensemble mais bien
évidemment elle ne peut pas le savoir
puisque à ce moment là elle est en
contact avec le stif qui n'a pas encore
voyager dans le temps
du coup après endgame il n'est pas
encore retourné dans le passé quoi mais
là où je suis le plus curieux c'est
concernant la fin du film de black widow
car alexei est toujours en vie et est
actif
il rêve de redevenir le raid guardian de
l'époque et omnubilé par captain america
sachant qu'un captain america 4 est
prévu raid guardian pourrait clairement
faire son retour comme un petit
happening pour affronter sam devenu le
nouveau captain america mais surtout
s'il existe une infime chance de revoir
steve en tant que vieux capitaine pour
conseiller sam et bucky il se pourrait
qu'une rencontre se fasse entre alexeï
et steve pour continuer comme je vous en
parlais dans la vidéo dédiée à la fin de
falcone et le soldat de l'hiver black
widow et reliés à la série et c'est
totalement confirmées de par la présence
de valentina allegra des fontaines
cette femme est au premier abord une
agent du shield et du gouvernement
américain sauf que le font contraste
totalement avec ce qui nous est montré
car oui dans les comics valentina fait
partie en réalité d'hydra et elle a
réussi à infiltrer le shield en tant que
l'une des meilleurs agents et par
rapport à ce qui nous est montré dans
falcone et le soldat de l'hiver et du
coup le film de black widow nous avons
moyen de déduire certaines choses je
vous en avais déjà parlé dans la vidéo
sur falcone mais il y a de grandes
chances que valentina commence à réunir
et à mettre au point l'équipe des
thunderbolts déjà dans le symbole nous
ne savons qu'elle n'est pas
bienveillante
elle souhaite promouvoir john walker à
la place de sam en tant que captain
america elle envoyait lena tu es aux
cayes
bref il est simple de comprendre qu'elle
est anti avengers sauf que valentina
n'est pas allé pêcher ses héros entre
guillemets au hasard
usa john tu fais partie des thunderbolts
dans les comics et jelena belova fait
partie des thunderbolts aussi sans
oublier que les personnages comme le
baron zemo ou encore taskmaster sont
toujours en vie et actifs et ils ont eux
aussi fait partie de l'équipe des
thunderbolts nous pouvons d'ailleurs
mentionné également deadpool le ghost
rider ou encore norman osborn qui sont
eux aussi lié à l'équipe des
thunderbolts et qui sont censés arriver
dans l'uem cu dans les prochaines années
sans oublier également celui qui serait
à la tête de tout ça dans le mc eu ta
des us
ross c'est une théorie que je vous avais
déjà partagé et mais ross est obsédé par
le sérum du super-soldat un sérum qu'il
a cherché à reproduire et la série sur
falcon nous montrer justement une
organisation qui cherchait à recréer le
sérum du super soldat
sans oublier que ross est anti avengers
également même s'il respecte des
personnages comme tony stark ou ce
qu'ils ont fait dans endgame roche
cherche à contrôler une équipe de super
héros étant le secrétaire d'état des
états unis ce dernier possède beaucoup
d'influx ans et beaucoup de pouvoir il
pourrait à fortes chances travailler
avec valentina qui agirait pour son
compte pour former cette fameuse équipe
d'antihéros toute façon c'est presque
quasiment acté us agent est un élément
important des thunderbolts est le seul
avenir qui nous a été montré c'est le
fait de travailler avec valentina dont
nous ignorons encore sa véritable nature
et bizarrement elena belova qui est
aussi une figure importante des
thunderbolts possède le
même à venir entre guillemets et
travaille pour la même personne
bizarrement que us agent les étoiles
sont alignées
j'ai envie de vous dire d'ailleurs pour
ceux qui ne savent pas mais ross est
censé devenir également leur aide
'le qu un membre très important des
thunderbolts voilà je le casse comme ça
comme ça vous le savez pour revenir plus
précisément sur clint qui va se faire
chasser par jelena
la logique voudrait que l'intrigué de
cette chasse à l'homme se passe durant
la série dédiée à hawk eye prévu pour
certainement décembre 2021 au cas il va
nous montrer sa passation de pouvoir
envers kate bishop qui deviendrait la
nouvelle aux cayes en quelque sorte
néanmoins le méchant de la série est
déjà à moitié confirmer puisque le
personnage de kenzy est confirmé pour la
série il s'agit du clown un antagoniste
de clint barton dans les comics donc je
ne vois pas trop où il y aurait de la
place pour y est lena belova sachant
pourtant que cette dernière est à moitié
confirmée elle aussi pour apparaître
dans la série 2 hawkeye et bien je me
dis que l'arrivée de jelena belova dans
la série pourrait se faire via la scène
post générique pourquoi pas en fait je
me dis que si marvel souhaite instaurer
l'équipe des thunderbolts c'est
peut-être un peu tôt de faire déjà une
confrontation entre elena et aux cayes
tout simplement car cette confrontation
à terme aboutir à sur la révélation de
la vérité concernant la mort de black
widow ielena clint va forcément lui
apprendre la vérité
alors oui il une vérité un petit peu
surprenante pour jelena je vais pas vous
mentir je suis pas sûr qu'elle accepte
dès le début de comprendre que black
widow s'est sacrifié pour une pierre
magique qui permet de vaincre à un gros
extraterrestre violet mais à terme on
sait que jelena fera partie des nouveaux
avengers et quelle est la relève
black widow donc si cette intrigue se
termine dans la série 2 hawkeye cela
gâche un petit peu la mise en place des
soldes hors boltz l'équipe serait un
petit peu gâché en quelque sorte
étant donné qu'il y ait un côté très
patriotique dans le futur conflit entre
les avengers et les thunderbolts puisque
ross et le secrétaire d'état que
valentina est infiltré aux usa l'équipe
est là entre guillemets pour confronter
les avengers qui viennent aussi des
états unis cela pourrait faire
l'intrigué du prochain captain america
falcone et le soldat de l'hiver est liée
à black widow et à captain america 4
annoncé à la fin de la série et les
captain america c'est toujours une
histoire un peu lié à la politique et le
gouvernement américain rappelez-vous de
first avengers du soldat de l'hiver ou
plus particulièrement de civil war
enfin bref voilà le film de black widow
était vraiment sympa et nous amène quand
même certaines questions à nous poser
j'ai très hâte de voir la suite des
événements peut-être que l'impact de
drake offre va se faire ressentir encore
plus tard dans le mc eu et que du coup
cela va nous préparer encore quelques
surprises pour la suite
et puis est-ce que jelena a bel et bien
sauvé toutes les assassins de l'arrêt
drôme au final on a très peu de réponses
mais en tout cas dites moi ce que vous
vous avez pensé du film est ce que vous
l'avez trouvé couler ce que vous avez
été
si peu déçu voilà je lirai tous les
commentaires comme d'habitude c'est un
vrai plaisir
puis n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à la chaîne
on se retrouve bien évidemment pour
l'eau qui épisode 6 le grand final j'ai
vraiment hâte
l'histoire s'écrit en ce moment même
allé bref écouter cet argot rock et que
le lionheart soit avec vous ciao tout le
monde
ah oui j'ai oublié je voulais vous
demander aussi en gros je me questionne
car j'ai fait une vidéo sur black widow
avant la sortie du film
c'est une question je rends mode
pourquoi black widow n'a pas eu
d'enterrement dans endgame et cetera
et vu que le film est sorti je sais pas
trop si c'est une bonne idée de sortir
cette vidéo j'en sais rien j'ai
l'impression qu'elle sert plus à rien
enfin je sais pas c'est à vous de me
dire si ça vous intéresse je verrai en
fonction de vous du coup
[Musique]